[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a Question and
Answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions.
PAUL SAXMAN: Hello, everybody.
Welcome to this week's Google
Maps Developer's Office Hours.
I'm Paul Saxman.
And with me this week is
somebody you probably
recognize but hasn't
been around for a
few weeks, Mano Marks.
What have you been
up to, Mano?
MANO MARKS: I got married.
PAUL SAXMAN: You got married.
MANO MARKS: And I went on my
honeymoon, so very exciting.
Spent a month in Italy.
I'll post pictures soon.
Not that anybody here cares,
but anyway, yeah, it was a
great time, a great time.
PAUL SAXMAN: I care.
MANO MARKS: Paul's been holding
down the fort here for
us this summer as a bunch
of us take our
honeymoons and vacations.
So thanks, Paul,
for doing that.
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh, my pleasure.
MANO MARKS: And he's
new to our team.
I guess regular viewers will
know him, know that he
recently joined the
Google Maps team.
So we're really happy to
have him on board.
PAUL SAXMAN: Cool.
Yeah, happy to be here.
It's a lot of fun working
back in data.
Some of you might recognize me
from Google TV, which is also
a really great product and a
really fun product at Google.
But yeah, likewise, this
is likewise pretty
exciting and fun.
So you know, I keep thinking,
like being Google Maps team,
we should probably have one of
these, like where in the world
is Google Maps Developer
Relations?
Because we tend to move around
for talks and stuff, and
things like honeymoons
in Italy and--
MANO MARKS: That would have
been even better last year
when we were spending
so much time.
I was on the road
50% of the time.
And we did 100 presentations,
actually 100 events, more than
100 presentations last year.
PAUL SAXMAN: Wow.
MANO MARKS: Yeah.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, so we'll look
into that following the
Carmen San Diego theme maybe.
So today, we have two
big topics we're
going to talk about.
One is the Google Places API
Developer Challenge.
And the other one is actually
something that we presented at
Google I/O, but Mano is
going to go into a
little more detail on.
That's the Google Maps API
Symbols and Heatmaps.
So Mano has some great examples
that we're going to
show and kind of pique you guys'
interest, hopefully.
It's kind of similar to what
we presented a couple weeks
ago when Brendan Kenny was on,
except this doesn't use WebGL.
This is just using overlays,
correct?
MANO MARKS: Right.
PAUL SAXMAN: Overlays
and markers.
MANO MARKS: It's something
that's integrated directly
with the API.
So yeah, we'll get a little
bit more into that.
But why don't we start
with the Places
API Developer Challenge.
PAUL SAXMAN: Great.
Yeah, so if you guys haven't
seen it yet, this last week,
we announced they were holding
a Google Places
API Developer Challenge.
We're kind of inviting
developers around the world to
actually work with local
municipalities--
cities and communities--
to develop apps that actually
solve problems in kind of the
local areas.
And these use the Google
Places API.
So that's kind of part of the
criteria, is find interesting
ways to use the API to kind
of help support your
municipality.
MANO MARKS: Why don't we show
the Challenge page--
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
Absolutely.
MANO MARKS: --to everybody
on the Live stream.
PAUL SAXMAN: I'm going
to steal the mouse
from you, Mano. o--
oops!
Can you maybe zoom
in a little bit?
MANO MARKS: You can use
the scroll wheel to
do that, can't you?
Or no, sorry.
He was just playing a video
game this morning, so--
PAUL SAXMAN: [LAUGHS]
Oops, sorry, that's the--
uh-oh, technical difficulties.
MANO MARKS: There we go.
PAUL SAXMAN: All right.
Now, how do we get out
of this mirror mode?
This is a Windows thing.
All right.
Well, we're going to go
with that for now.
Little distracting for
some of you, but--
so this is the Challenge website
as you can see here.
Let's get rid of that.
MANO MARKS: Here.
PAUL SAXMAN: There we go.
Nice.
So the website is
developers@googl
e.com/places/challenge.
All the information that you
need to know about the
Challenge is there, including
the registration forms.
MANO MARKS: We'll post
the links, too,
after this Live stream.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, absolutely.
So we have some videos to kind
of explain the Challenge to
you, a lot of information on the
site in general about it.
But what you're going to want
to check out-- so there's a
few things that are really
important here.
One is the timeframe.
So it's actually a pretty
long timeframe.
The judging doesn't start
actually until November 1.
So actually the Challenge
ends October 31.
MANO MARKS: Right.
PAUL SAXMAN: So I believe
that's about what?
I think 10 weeks from about now
or maybe August 15 when
submission begins.
So it gives developers a lot
of time to kind of work out
their ideas, kind of submit
their applications, and get
them judged.
MANO MARKS: Tell them
what they get.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, that's--
MANO MARKS: If they win.
PAUL SAXMAN: That's
kind of the--
probably the most important
part to some people.
So over on the Prizes page,
what you could see-- so
there's two different
judging categories.
There's the Judge's Choice
Award, which is actually
obviously determined by the
judges, or the winners are
determined by the judges.
There's also a People's
Choice Award.
So it's important for you guys
to kind of spread the word.
If you're developing an app,
spread the word to people you
know so that they can
get in there and--
MANO MARKS: Judge your--
PAUL SAXMAN: --judge your app.
MANO MARKS: Yeah.
We're not going to do a toll
call that you have to--
no 900 numbers or--
PAUL SAXMAN: No, absolutely.
MANO MARKS: --whatever people
are doing these days for that.
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh, yeah, right.
Yeah, spread the wealth.
So there's two Google I/O
tickets that are actually part
of the Judge's Choice Award.
And also, there's a travel
stipend as well.
So it'll get you to I/O. And I
think that's more than enough
for a hotel in San Francisco.
MANO MARKS: Oh, yeah.
PAUL SAXMAN: To tell you the
truth, I haven't stayed in a
hotel in San Francisco for
a little while, but--
MANO MARKS: That's true.
PAUL SAXMAN: You know, another
great thing about this is it's
a chance to get some
notoriety.
You get to actually potentially
showcase your app
at Google I/O 2013.
And I mean, this is well worth
it right here-- dinner with
the Google Maps and
Places API team.
So you can potentially
hang out with us.
MANO MARKS: That's right.
PAUL SAXMAN: Some of
the organizers,
potentially some judges.
MANO MARKS: And we eat well.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
MANO MARKS: Let me tell you.
And so runners up, runners up
also have some really great
prizes as well.
We have Google Nexus 7 Tablets,
15-minute hangouts
with a Google executive
to be determined.
And People Choice Awards,
I think it's equally as
compelling.
I think it's-- well, pretty
much the same
as the Judge's Award--
two I/O tickets, $3,500 travel
stipend, and showcasing your
app at I/O, and dinner
as well.
MANO MARKS: So a total
of six entries can--
I guess, sorry--
PAUL SAXMAN: So we have--
MANO MARKS: --seven entries.
So three Judge's Choice awards,
one People's Choice
award will win the top prize.
And then three runners up will
get to the Nexus Tablet and
the hangout with the
Google executive.
PAUL SAXMAN: All right.
So over on the rules, I'm
not going to read
this to you guys online.
But it's pretty long.
And I think it's pretty
important to just to kind of
get an idea of what the
application entails.
A big thing here is it must use
municipal data or city or
community data, and it must
use the Places API.
A lot of information about
prizes, privacy,
et cetera, et cetera.
There's one other thing
I wanted to mention.
Judging, oh, team size--
it can be an individual
project as well.
So if you want to use those
two tickets to bring your
significant other to Google I/O,
you can do that as well.
MANO MARKS: That's right.
PAUL SAXMAN: Entering is
just a simple form.
This gets you on the list, gets
you information updates.
And another really important
thing on the site here--
the resources.
So here's where we're
actually posting--
well, not only information about
the Google Places API,
which is spread out through our
developer documentation,
but here's a list
of data sources.
And we're going to continue
to add more data sources.
Actually, we're going to add
more hopefully this week and
throughout the duration
of the Challenge.
So keep your eye on
this page if maybe
your city's not listed.
And definitely feel free to send
information our way if
you think there's data sources
that we should potentially
post up here.
And this is an international--
like I said, an international
challenge, so anybody in these
countries is welcome to
participate and a number of
other countries.
And this is one thing that--
oh, yeah-- that was interesting
in the rules.
Of course, there's a few
countries that aren't able to
participate listed up
at the top here.
But that shouldn't be a
surprise to anybody.
And the FAQ at the bottom here,
keep giving us your
questions, and we'll keep
this updated for
the rest of the community.
MANO MARKS: And, of course, you
can always ask questions
on our regular Office Hours
or on Stack Overflow about
particulars of using
the Places API.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
Yeah, we're getting a good
number of questions these days
about Places API on
Stack Overflow.
I monitor it every day, and
there's a few other team
members that do.
So definitely, if you have any
questions, obviously, search
Stack Overflow because your
question might have been
answered already.
MANO MARKS: What's your
Stack Overflow score?
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh, not even
close to yours.
[CHUCKLES]
Yeah, I've actually been a
Stack Overflow user for I
think, geez, like quite a few
years, since I think 2007 or
something like that.
But my score was pretty level
for quite a long time.
So it's only in the
last year or two.
But I think I saw yours,
which is impressive.
MANO MARKS: What's great about
Stack Overflow is your score
can grow as people--
I was on my honeymoon.
I came back from my honeymoon,
and it had grown like 100
points because people found my
old answers and up-voted them.
But anyway, enough about that.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
MANO MARKS: Yeah,
anything more on
the Developer Challenge?
PAUL SAXMAN: No, I
think that's it.
Maybe in a week or two, we
could have somebody--
one of the organizers of
the Challenge, so--
MANO MARKS: Yeah--
PAUL SAXMAN: --from our
marketing team.
MANO MARKS: --can come on and
answer some questions
specifically about
the Challenge.
PAUL SAXMAN: And besides that,
yeah, just let us know any
questions you guys
have, any ideas.
We're happy to communicate with
you guys over Google+,
Stack Overflow.
MANO MARKS: Right.
PAUL SAXMAN: So we're looking
forward to seeing what you
guys put together.
MANO MARKS: OK.
PAUL SAXMAN: On to--
let's give the mouse
back to you.
MANO MARKS: OK.
So there was a great session at
Google I/O called Spatial
Data Visualization.
And I gather that Brendan was on
a couple weeks ago and did
a great job talking about some
of the WebGL intricacies and
the amazing things that
you can do with WebGL.
For those of you who don't want
to quite go that far, you
might be interested in our new
Heatmap and Symbols services
and APIs in the Google
Maps API.
So we're pretty excited
about this.
So what is a Heatmap, though?
Often, when I talk about
Heatmaps, people immediately
assume I'm talking about
temperature.
And no matter how much I talk
about other things, they just
can't get the word Heatmap
out of their minds.
So a way to think of this
is intensity maps.
It's really trying to show
intensity of objects at a
location, or things at a
location, data points.
So here's an example.
This is intensity of airports
around the world.
And the reason they're called
Heatmaps is because they use a
color scheme often-- not
always, but often--
that we are familiar with from
weather forecasts for heat.
So red is hot, so lots of
intensity there, lots of
things there.
Yellow is less hot.
And then green is
even more so.
And this one actually shows--
you can see here it's mostly
yellow and green around
the world.
But as I zoom out, you can see
that the intensity changes.
And you can see the
concentration changes because
as I zoom out, the areas that
are represented are smaller.
So you see it here.
You get some deep red areas.
So this is just using
the Google Maps API.
And it uses the Visualization
library, which you can add
very easily to--
you just add it as a parameter
in the loader.
And then you just add data.
And it's just the more points
that you add to the Heatmap at
a particular location, the
more there are there.
PAUL SAXMAN: So I was
kind of amazed.
I was playing around
with the--
it's a Heatmap overlay, right?
You get a overlay object that
you could put over your map
and how easy it was actually
load data.
So I was thinking like, oh, I'm
going to have to process
or parse a CSV file.
Or I was going to have to get
data, load it from some ugly
format into the API, and
actually parse it, and load it
into the overlay.
And no, it was a lot
easier than that.
I just had to have a JSON
file that had all the
data loaded into it.
MANO MARKS: That's right.
PAUL SAXMAN: Making a JSON
file was really simple.
Then all you do is you
load the JSON file
as a script, right?
And that actually--
so JSON is JavaScript.
You can tell I come from a Java
background because I have
to parse everything in Java.
But yeah, you load the JSON
file into the script.
It loads it as data.
And then the data is just passed
directly as an object
to the overlay.
So no parsing necessary as long
as you have the JSON file
in the first place.
MANO MARKS: And there's
a lot of different
options you can use.
So you can control-- for
instance, you can see this
changes as I zoom
in and zoom out.
But sometimes, you want
that to stay the same.
So if I go to this next one,
this is the same example.
You see, as I zoom in and zoom
out, it actually retains the
same color values.
And that's useful because
as you're zooming in--
say I zoom in Vancouver on this
other example, you'll see
it kind of spreads out.
And then suddenly, you've
lost the Heatmap as
you get really close.
And that's useful
in some cases.
But in other cases, you want
to retain that area of high
intensity on the map.
You can also control
things like color.
And this is an interesting
example where we use both
styled maps and the changing
the color of the Heatmap.
So you can see that it uses
a slightly different color
scheme and made all
the water black.
And you can use it, of course,
on a variety of different--
you can use it on top of
satellite view regular maps,
hybrid view, anything that we
have, or your own custom maps.
PAUL SAXMAN: Can we--
MANO MARKS: You can sort of
toggle them on and off, yeah?
PAUL SAXMAN: I was just
going to say, I think
they're really cool.
So compared to what Brendan
showed a couple weeks ago with
the WebGL, which is very
powerful tool, but then you do
a lot of WebGL programming.
I mean, you're responsible
for actually doing
the rendering yourself.
What does the code
look like here?
I mean--
MANO MARKS: Oh, that's
really good question.
PAUL SAXMAN: What is necessary
on the developer side?
MANO MARKS: Let's
take a look at--
let's view the source here.
PAUL SAXMAN: It's the magic
control sequence.
Right.
There we go.
MANO MARKS: So standard loader--
see, you add this
libraries=visualization.
Here, we're loading
a JSON object.
And here, whoever created
this sample--
actually, it was Enoch who
presented this at Google I/O--
put in polygons to cover up the
oceans because that's his
favorite way of doing that.
So then, here's your standard
creating your map code.
You create a new data object,
this MVCArray.
And then you pass it to
the HeatmapLayer.
And then you just add data
points to the HeatmapLayer.
And that's it.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, so it's--
MANO MARKS: So it's
really simple.
PAUL SAXMAN: To actually get
the Heatmap overlay, you're
looking at seven, eight
lines of code?
MANO MARKS: Right.
PAUL SAXMAN: Right.
MANO MARKS: Yeah, and it's
important to emphasize this is
all done client-side.
This is all loaded
into the browser.
So that data doesn't get sent to
Google, and then generating
an overlay, and then sent back,
which is what we did
with the FusionTablesLayer.
So Fusion Tables had a great
Heatmap functionality that a
lot of people like.
It has that functionality,
and that still remains
an option to you.
But if you can do it in
client-side, this actually
makes, I think, a smoother
transition and a
more dynamic one.
If you take a look here at this
example, as I said, you
can toggle on and
off the Heatmap.
But you can also change the
gradient, so you can change
the colors.
You can change the radius of the
points, and you can change
the opacity and a lot of
other options as well.
So you get a lot of dynamism
because it
happens in the client.
It doesn't have to go
back to the server
to regenerate something.
PAUL SAXMAN: So how might--
I mean, so I can definitely
see the kind of scientific
application of this, so if
you're analyzing a certain
data set and you want
to see it on a map.
MANO MARKS: Sure.
PAUL SAXMAN: But how might
you integrate this
into a Web 2.0 app?
Like what are some good use
cases for using Heatmaps in a
non-scientific application?
MANO MARKS: Well, so this is
an interesting data set.
This is taxi rides
in San Francisco.
So that might be something
that you could use to
demonstrate to your customers
where there's an
intensity of locations.
So you can see there's
a lot of taxis.
Say this data set was taxis,
where the taxis are right now.
So if I wanted to go find a
taxi, I would go down there.
Or a cafe or some other thing,
you could show where
restaurants were or something
like that.
So there's a lot of
potential there.
So if I want to go out on a
Saturday night and I want to
see where things are, not
necessarily want to go to a
particular restaurant, but I
want to go to a neighborhood
and just like hang out, go to a
bar, or go to a restaurant,
and just like in a sense of that
neighborhood, that would
give me a sense of which
neighborhoods to attend if
I'm, for instance, using Google
Places to find those.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
Very cool.
So, yeah, so that's a good
point, is I think a lot of
municipal data actually is
kind of street by street,
neighborhood by neighborhood.
So you could potentially use the
Heatmaps to kind of show
certain things about certain
streets, neighborhoods, areas
of the city.
MANO MARKS: And then, of course,
crime statistics,
another classic example
of using Heatmaps
or demographic data.
PAUL SAXMAN: And then my next
one is going to be cafe
density because I'm always
looking for if there are good
places to hang out on the
weekends when I'm not busy.
MANO MARKS: So--
PAUL SAXMAN: --I
need a laptop.
MANO MARKS: --this next sample
actually shows how the
dynamism of the HeatmapLayer,
which is that I can actually--
basically, every time I
move the mouse, it's
creating a new point.
And that allows me to just sort
of track the movements,
the areas in which somebody
is going on this map.
This is actually not a map
that's particularly useful.
But it does show how the
Heatmap can just--
as you're getting data, you
can just keep adding to it
based on user input.
Or you can--
you know, more stuff being
loaded from your server side.
PAUL SAXMAN: Right.
Yeah, exactly, because
it is JSON.
So you can just dynamically,
constantly, just make--
MANO MARKS: Exactly.
PAUL SAXMAN: --like requests.
MANO MARKS: In response
to an event, just add.
And you see, if I can just hover
over this one point and
just add a whole bunch of
points, it actually starts to
affect the rest of
the Heatmap.
And you start to see some
shrinkage in the intensity in
other areas.
So I think that's a really fun
and interesting example.
PAUL SAXMAN: Very cool.
MANO MARKS: So I think we're
going to switch gears here and
start talking about symbols.
So Symbols is a new addition
to polylines and markers in
the Google Maps API.
And the idea here is that for
a long time you've been able
to do custom markers
in the Maps API.
You can use your own icon
for the marker.
However, doing custom lines
really wasn't that useful.
And loading in the custom
markers, you were loading in
an image, a particular image
that was reused.
So Symbols now allows you to
use SVG, Scalable Vector
Graphics, to change how both
lines and markers look and are
represented.
And this gives you a
lot of dynamism.
So we've built in some
default styles.
So this is actually in response
to a lot of requests
that we've gotten over the years
for this kind of thing.
You see here this line
is actually an arrow.
PAUL SAXMAN: So is it just
a simple polyline, right?
MANO MARKS: It's a simple
polyline styled as an arrow.
And this is one of our
default styles.
This is another one,
a dashed line.
Often, very common request that
we never accommodated
before, but we do believe with
the spread of support for SVG,
and Canvas, and other
technologies that we use to
implement this, we
can now do this.
PAUL SAXMAN: And again, since
this is a polyline, this is
client-side again, right?
MANO MARKS: Yeah, it's all being
rendered client-side.
That's correct.
PAUL SAXMAN: So, you
as a developer, you
provide some kind of--
you either say what you want
the line to look like using
one of our pre-canned styles
or you can provide SVG
parameters.
MANO MARKS: That's right.
So this, for instance, see
there's a little happy face, a
little X, a little
dot at the end.
You get quite a bit of
control over this.
And this is all done
by SVG that's just
defined in the page.
Actually, let's take a look
at the source on that one.
So you see here, it's--
PAUL SAXMAN: Want me to
zoom in a little bit?
MANO MARKS: Yeah.
Thank you.
Help me, too.
[CHUCKLES]
So you see here standard
map loading.
And then you create a line.
And this just has two
points on it.
And then you create different
symbols using SVG, and
symbolOne, symbolTwo,
symbolThree.
And then with the line, you
create this new polyline.
You give it the path, the line
coordinates, and then you put
in these icons.
And there's a number
of different things
you can do on here.
You can put in the offset.
And the offset can either be a
percentage or a pixel value.
And that allows you to define
where on the line
something shows up.
Now, this brings an
interesting point
and why we used SVG.
SVG is Scalable Vector
Graphics.
If you were to use icons, and
you were to do something like
this, zoom in, it
would distort.
The icon would eventually
be distorted.
Or it would get too small
if you zoomed out.
But because it's using
SVG, it scales.
You're just defining where
the vectors are.
So it scales so that you
get a nice, clean
representation each time.
PAUL SAXMAN: And also,
I think it was--
well, maybe we'll see what
your next tab is.
Are you going to Markers?
Or--
MANO MARKS: I was going
to Animation.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, right.
MANO MARKS: So again, because
it's SVG but it's all
happening in the client,
we can do things
like alter the offsets.
And so you can just have a
little timed thing that alters
the offset, and it actually
moves it around.
So this is--
let's take a look at the
source for this.
So again, line, symbol,
polyline, and the offset.
And has it starts at 100%, which
means it starts at the
end of the line.
And then it just has a function,
animateCircle, which
moves that circle.
Every count, it moves that
circle a little bit, offsets
it, changes the offset.
And then it just
keeps running.
So animateCircle just keeps
looping around.
So very simple to do really
interesting animations.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
So all it needs, you just have
to modify the variable on the
symbol to actually get it
to-- or on the polyline
actually--to get it to--
MANO MARKS: That's right.
PAUL SAXMAN: Very cool.
MANO MARKS: So this sample
actually takes advantage of
our Elevation API, and
ElevationService, rather.
The ElevationService allows you
to say, give me all the
elevations along a path
at so many intervals.
And this says at every
500 meters.
And so then, we create
a new line that
goes sort of off that.
Well, this is actually
a good example.
I'm going to zoom in.
You can see there's actually
individual lines here.
And then each line, the length
of the line, is by the height
of the elevation
at that point.
And then you'll see there's a
different line that creates
sort of a shadow off of it.
And these lines are all at an
angle that was calculated off
where it was on the line.
PAUL SAXMAN: So this is kind of
a cool visualization for,
let's say, if you want
to do a bike riding--
MANO MARKS: Yeah, that would--
PAUL SAXMAN: --tour map or
something like that.
MANO MARKS: That would be
a really good idea.
PAUL SAXMAN: So you
could put all your
data in the map itself.
MANO MARKS: Exactly.
So those are the
samples I had.
I, unfortunately, wasn't able to
play a video that I've got.
But what I would suggest, if
you're interested in this,
check out the Google I/O
presentation that Enoch Lau
and Brendan Kenny did.
Enoch spent a lot of
time talking about
these different details.
And then also check out the
What's New in the Google Maps
API session that was done by
Brian McClendon, Peter Birch,
Dylan Lorimer, and
Thor Mitchell.
And Thor Mitchell has a really
great video where he shows all
the planes that arrive
in and out of San
Francisco in a given day.
And that video was done using
the Maps API and animating.
And he actually animates them
flying on and off, flying to
and from their destinations,
so really, really powerful
visualization.
We'll post links to both those
presentations in the Google
Maps API page, Google+ page.
PAUL SAXMAN: Awesome.
So I'm not over here
checking email.
I'm bringing up the questions.
MANO MARKS: Right.
OK.
So, yeah, now-- and now,
your questions.
So we're going over
to Google--
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
[?
MANO MARKS: Is it Moderator?
PAUL SAXMAN: So yeah, we
have Moderator running.
Actually, I think I set
the Moderator timer
to turn off at 10:30.
So if you have any questions,
I'm going to go over to the
YouTube Live, and we'll check
the comments there as well.
MANO MARKS: OK.
PAUL SAXMAN: But we'll
start out with
what we have in Moderator.
MANO MARKS: We didn't put
this up on the screen.
So yeah, why don't you just
go ahead and read
their questions then.
PAUL SAXMAN: Sure.
So we're going to try to get
the ones that are either--
so OK. "The HeatmapsLayer has
presentation options, but once
rendered doesn't seem to have
events or interaction options.
Is this true or a misreading
of the Docs?" So in
referencing--
so events or interaction
options on Heatmaps.
MANO MARKS: Yeah.
So anything that it's going
to have on the layer--
it's an MVC object, so it'll
inherit whatever other layers
have, the sort of the basic
MVC layer objects have.
I actually am kind
of blanking.
I don't think it has a onClick
event or the standard--
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh, I see
what he's saying.
MANO MARKS: --click events.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
MANO MARKS: But I'll have
to take a closer
look at those Docs.
And maybe we can circle back
to that next time.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, that's
a very good point.
We got a couple questions
about Google Glass.
Unfortunately, we're probably
not going to answer those--
MANO MARKS: Yeah.
PAUL SAXMAN: --since it's--
MANO MARKS: It's not our team.
And so we're not qualified
to answer the
Google Glass questions.
PAUL SAXMAN: Especially
distribution.
MANO MARKS: Yeah.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, definitely.
We'll see about posting
something about where you guys
can find information about
that stuff because--
MANO MARKS: Right.
PAUL SAXMAN: --because
it might not be
widely available yet.
And so "Google Maps Navigation,
is there an API
that will integrate
with Google Maps?
And then, "we'd love to be able
to take users along our
routes using Google
Turn-by-Turn."
MANO MARKS: So that's a
really good question.
And neither of us is on
the Android team.
So we really probably aren't the
most qualified people to
answer that.
However, I will say
that Navigation
doesn't have an API.
But it does allow you to launch
it with an Intent.
So I would look into what it
supports with the Intents.
I'm not sure if it supports
a particular route--
probably does--
or a particular destination.
Yeah, so as I said, no API at
this point that I know of.
But you might want to check out
the Android Office Hours
for more information.
PAUL SAXMAN: Mm-hm.
I mean, we do also have the
Google Directions API.
So you can get route
information.
MANO MARKS: Right.
It just doesn't allow you
to do that turn by turn.
PAUL SAXMAN: Right.
MANO MARKS: Yeah.
PAUL SAXMAN: So it
looks like--
oh, Live comments,
here we are.
"How can you animate a Heatmap
using a Google Drive table?
Can you show some code?"
MANO MARKS: So I don't think
either of us have any code
ready for that.
So that's a really
good question.
You would have to draw, I would
imagine, just on the--
so Google Drive table instance
is basically a Fusion Table.
So you'd just need to pull out
your data using the API,
create some JSON, and push
it into Maps API.
PAUL SAXMAN: So it's
all about the JSON.
Does the Fusion Tables
have export to JSON
or a JSON feed interface?
MANO MARKS: You know, they
released a new API while I was
on my honeymoon.
And I haven't taken
a look at it.
So, yeah, unfortunately,
I don't know.
But ask the question on Stack
Overflow and I think we can
get some more information.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, I think it's
fair to mention that you
just returned yesterday
from your honeymoon.
MANO MARKS: Yes, that was
my first day back.
PAUL SAXMAN: So your email
backlog is still probably
pretty massive.
Looks like that's pretty
much it for questions.
If you guys have anything,
feel free
to comment on Google+.
We're going to post a link to
the recording, the YouTube
recording, on our
Google+ stream.
So feel free to add comments
or questions there.
We'd love to hear
from you guys.
So any feedback you guys have
is much appreciated.
MANO MARKS: And I believe
next week, there's an
Australia-friendly time
Office Hours.
So Chris and Luke will
look forward to
talking to you then.
PAUL SAXMAN: Mm-hm Yeah, we'll
be sure that gets posted on
the Google Developers Live
calendar so you guys can get
some advance notice.
So I think that's everything
today.
Thanks for hanging
out with us.
And looking forward to having
you guys at a future event.
MANO MARKS: Yeah.
PAUL SAXMAN: So--
MANO MARKS: All right.
Good to be back.
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh, yeah.
Welcome back, Mano.
MANO MARKS: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]